the Joe Rogan experience that concerns I
think classical liberals and if that's
how you would describe yourself I don't
know what to all of us in the political
world Joe Rogan's political leanings are
like the great mystery and frankly we
kind of like it that way it makes you it
keeps you out of the fray it's more than
missing as I said that I wouldn't vote
for Biden that I said I would vote for
Trump / Biden all these people went
crazy but let me let me you know what
I'd also vote for Whoopi Goldberg / Joe
Biden I'd vote for Mike Tyson / Joe
Biden I just don't think it's a good
idea to take someone who's struggling
with dementia and put them in one of the
most stressful positions the world has
ever known
that's what I'm saying I mean is that an
endorsement of Trump is it is a me
saying you shouldn't have a man who's
clearly clearly in the throes of
dementia I mean there's I'm not a doctor
but when you can't form sentences in
public and you forget what you're
talking about and you you're you wander
off into these conversations if you're
not smoking pot you're not high if
you're not on pills like what's going on
well there's cognitive decline he's an
older man that has mental issues and you
know not to be cruel to him he's he's
suffering medically this is it is a real
issue and the Democrats want to sweep
that under the rug and Trump is already
chewing him apart he's already
dismissing him I mean there is a recent
thing that Kyle kolinsky posted a video
on his Twitter talking about this is
what happens when you don't discuss the
elephant in the room and it's Trump
saying used to do it doing a press
conference and they asked him a question
about something that Biden wrote he was
but I didn't write that he's like he
said that's a democratic operative he
didn't read it he probably doesn't even
know what's going on right now and he's
gonna he's gonna continue to do that and
it's it's such a vulnerable point and I
I don't know why the Democrats thought
it would be a good idea to take someone
who's clearly got a problem and this is
I mean I don't want to be mean to the
guy but we've all seen it that's not
normal
it's not normal to forget like when he's
talking about the creator and he
literally lose
what he's saying he's like other do you
know the thing like the Declaration of
Independence yes now I mean that's a
very simple document there's a bunch of
those things like when he was talking
about the Cure and losing what he's
saying that you have to take care of the
cure and he's he's struggling the guy's
struggling he's tired this is his
extremely stressful process to run for
president and the idea that he's going
to be able to get through this and be
okay on the other side to run the
country for for potentially eight years
is crazy yeah and on a more from a
policy perspective if we're looking at
the coronavirus in particular and the
handling of it you know this is
obviously the subject of hot debate you
know there's there's plenty of bad faith
journalists out there who who continue
and politicians including Pelosi who
continue to repeat that Trump has the
the deaths of thousands on his hands I
think that's a horrible horrible
overstatement I mean to say the least
it's just fundamentally not true but we
need to remember Joe Biden just recently
acknowledged that he now agrees with
Trump's decision to close down travel
from China in January and I go through a
long I recorded a podcast I almost have
as many subscribers as you do
now I'm sure ya know I don't where I go
through a timeline of what actually
happened right like let's let's actually
look into this debate in an objective
way of who knew what and when because
you can criticize people for sure and it
cuz hindsight is 20/20 but it's
important to put yourself in the moment
and what we all knew at certain times
the certain decisions were made and I
have to point out that that when we did
this travel restriction from China in
late January at that same time the World
Health Organization was saying that was
repeating Chinese claims in mid-january
that this virus couldn't even be
transmitted in human to human contact
you know and Trump was ripped apart for
that Biden ripped him apart for that
button continued to rip him apart for
that up until a couple weeks ago so like
you know these decisions saved countless
lives and and and it's pretty obvious
that Biden I mean he said it so of
course it's obvious that he would have
made a difference
and we would be in a much different
place right now to put aside all of the
issues that you pointed out those are
those are certainly issues and I don't
need to repeat them underneath to go
into it but it's why I feel like we do
the dollar it is obvious but that's
crazy that this is the guy that's
running for president you know and then
when people got upset at saying that you
know me me saying that I would vote I'd
probably vote for Trump before I would
vote for Biden I'm literally saying I'd
vote for anybody that can talk I mean
anyone who's not in in severe cognitive
decline I mean pick a person should I
vote for Hillary before I'd vote for him
literally I mean I just I just think the
poor guy shouldn't be in the position
he's in I don't understand why they're
doing that I mean anyone else could have
been Tulsi Gabbard Amy Klobuchar people
to judge pick a person they all would
have been a better choice I mean this is
crazy and I don't know what their
strategy is I don't know why they
decided to do this it makes no sense to
me it's very very confusing
[Applause]